TJ is with us TJ's in Atlanta hi TJ how
are you hey David it's great to talk to
you
hey I got a I got a thing we've been my
wife and I've been knocking out debt
using your every dollar online and she
came to me the other day she goes man I
can save us a hundred and twenty plus
dollars a month on our phone bill and I
said what's it about and it was about
switching from Verizon for four of us
over - Xfinity mobile since we were
already customers she went online and we
checked the website make sure the phones
were compatible and all but to work so
we used our cash in our general savings
account since our merchant account was
already good we paid cash for two new
phones and went in to activate the
phones and long story short we
discovered that they're not they are not
able to bring any phones from any
network so they said well you can bite
four phones and there's a bull ways day
and so now we're kind of stuck I thought
you said to a more compatible they are
according to the website as today but
they're no they're not honoring that
right now according to their tier two
supervisors and that's our Xfinity
that's Xfinity mobile up on their
website and we've even called the CEO
and the vice president of marketing and
they said they will give us $200 or $100
off each of the new phones that we buy
but that's an $800 phone you know they
should have done they should have fixed
this before you called a show and told
fifteen million people how you guys I
asked us that well if you'll give me two
new phones I already bought two if you
give me two new phones we'll be rocking
and rolling and I'll save one hundred
plus dollars a month yeah or give me a
year free and I'll buy two new phones
yeah yeah so I'm thinking about maybe
calling like a consumer you know folks
here in Atlanta I mean can you imagine
what people I mean 15 million people
just heard this story what that cost
them they should have given them they
should have given you a couple phones I
mean they like to honor their word in
other words
we're saying you're saying it's plainly
stated on I've not looked at it but
you're saying it's plainly stated on the
right on the website on their TV
commercials as well as on the website as
of today you can go in there and it says
put in your phone you put in your
provider your phone and it tells you yep
it's compatible and the stores are
evening thinking it's compatible because
we had to go into the store and when I
told the manager went back to her and
told her that they told me that they're
not honoring they're like and this has
been up about a seven or eight day
episode man trying to get it figured out
that's so I aggravating so can you go
back yes the other phones the two phones
that are compatible or still on Verizon
so Italy Verizon account still open just
reactivate your others and tell Xfinity
to stick it right that's what I would do
I couldn't give them money if what
you're saying is true all right you know
if I were in right you know you feel
like you got screwed don't do business
people are screwing you yeah I mean well
we've been customers a bit with Xfinity
17 years and had wonderful experience
and we couldn't believe that we were
having this problem and the store kept
saying it was a security issue and when
we got a call back from their customer
support two separate days they told us
that we don't support comes from under
you know other providers for aizen or
whoever it is and you have to buy all
new phones and so yeah I can't fix it I
don't know what to tell you I mean I you
know you're asking my opinion I'd
probably just go back where I was and
I'd be willing to pay more than I'll
deal with somebody scrutiny is the way I
would feel about it but
yeah that just cost them a whole lot of
money Wow can you imagine the number of
people listening to this right now
if you work for a xfinity hey hold him
on the line get his phone number if you
work for Xfinity and you actually want
to make that right I'll give you a
chance to make it right right here on
the air if you actually want to let grow
a backbone then do the right thing we'll
fix that guy up but if you don't then I
guess you just got trashed Wow this is
the Dave Ramsey show